when they assassinated a revered General
in Iraq violating Iraqi sovereignty they
thought as Secretary Pompeo treated that
people would be dancing in the streets
of Tehran and Baghdad actually he picked
up a small gathering of of a few and
tweeted that we rid the region of a
whatever he want to call him and then
people are dancing that showed two
things which are very dangerous and when
combined it becomes even more dangerous
ignorance and arrogance and when you
become an arrogant ignorant or an
ignorant arrogant it becomes a disaster
particularly if you have a lot of power
that has been fueling may have in the
region